one of the things i love about cooking
and that keeps me excited after 25 years
behind the stove
is that there's always something new to
learn every day new ingredients
new techniques and new cuisines
start off with the stuffing it's amazing
how
exciting a stuffed roast chicken can be
because it keeps the chicken incredibly
moist and gives a delicious texture
inside the bird i'm going to start off
with cured
cereso this is a traditional spanish
sausage and it's
garlicky spicy incredibly meaty
that gives a little bit of sort of
richness to the stuffing get that cerezo
in start cooking that down
and getting all those oils out touch
the olive oil in there to get it going
right onions
chopped add the onions to the ceriso
and in a matter of seconds they'll
change color as they soak up all the
flavor
that lovely spiciness has been stolen
from that sausage
now the onions smell incredible
garlic garlic
fresh thyme just hold it down and put
your fingers on there and it's a really
nice way of taking off all those nice
fragrant little time flowers
you can hear it crackling in the
background
these are cannellini beans they're waxy
very soft and so delicious but very
dense
but for stuffing they're so robust
nothing breaks down
drain them off
in they're going to take on all that
juice
as well from this freezer i'm going to
season them now because they're very
dense so it needs some help
and that looks like it's a dish on its
own
good enough to eat now i want to sweeten
things up a little bit
tomatoes half dried in
that sweetens up the stuffing
beautiful the stuffing's ready look at
the color everything
looks spanish it looks delicious now
stuffing the chicken i like taking off
these little knuckles
as the chicken cooks the skin stretches
over the bone you can get a really nice
drum
and take off those little wingtips as
well salt pepper
so important now
your stuffing i want to go right inside
the chicken
push it down this really helps to cook
the bird evenly because you're
pushing out all the empty spaces in the
carcass
and take a nice large lemon
push the lemon in pick up the person's
nose
pull the skin over olive oil on top
salt and pepper
a teaspoon of paprika sprinkle it on
and then get your hands and sort of
rub that in and see what the paprika is
doing to the chicken
putting this like sweet spicy marinade
it's not even roasted yet but it looks
delicious
400 ml of white wine same quantity of
water that helps
the chicken to steam chicken in
be generous with the time sprigs
[Music]
make sure the fall is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chicken
steams in the oven
keeping it moist and juicy into the oven
[Music]
cook for one hour at 180 degrees with a
foil on
nice take it out and remove the full lid
then give it another 30 minutes to crisp
up that skin
[Music]
look at that it's so important
to make sure you take that tinfoil off
with half an hour to go beautiful
pierce that open squeeze it in that
delicious gravy
mix that into the tray
and sieve that
that's really nice fragrant lemony
spiced
roasting juices to finish
before we cut up the chicken take out
that amazing stuffing
[Music]
incredible i'd have that with chicken
over potatoes any day
and then just get your chicken roasting
juices
now to cut the chicken up
hold the drum and slice straight through
and there's that wonderful drum and the
thigh
through the wishbone
off slice with the point at an angle so
you can see the texture of that amazing
roast chicken
just take my cooking juices just want to
give a really nice sort of lemony
flavor over my chicken
and there you go a delicious
very charming stuffed roast chicken
[Music]
start by thoroughly coating the fish in
seasoned flour
and then just roll it just touch looking
for a springy
firm texture